world leaders have condemned russia's
latest offensive in ukraine's east the
kremlin is seeking to make up for recent
military losses around the capital kyiv
by seizing control of the country's
industrial heartland
areas marked in blue are already under
russian control a new front line shown
in red stretches along nearly 500
kilometers
moscow says securing the donbass region
is now the main goal of its so-called
special military operation our next
report contains images that you might
find distressing
more ukrainian civilians killed by
russian shelling
in a residential apartment block in
kharkiv
a man recognizes his neighbor
he worked in security nearby
every day he went to get food every day
the shelling began and we fled when we
came back the old man was already dead
closer to the front lines in kramatorsk
more victims of russian bombardment
the increased shelling has not only
added to the numbers of dead it has also
forced ukraine to suspend evacuation
efforts for the living
to the south
only one part of mariupol still remains
in ukrainian hands
the azov stall metalworks
the azov battalion who are holding out
against russian forces
say they're protecting civilians
hiding from the bombs in a bunker below
the metalworks
there are counts of life under siege
my youngest child cries at everything he
twitches in his sleep
he and the eldest are starting to get
depressed
they miss their peaceful life it's been
really frightening lately
frightening even to go out to use the
toilet
those who are responsible for this war
who unleashed this war against us
i wish they would have to go through all
this pain themselves
and their children too
russian state media claimed that 120
civilians from the azov stall plant left
on tuesday via humanitarian corridors
but mariupol's city council said more
than a thousand were taking refuge here
an adviser to ukraine's president says
russia has begun firing bunker-busting
munitions at the shelter
which may still be harboring children
well a commander of ukrainian marines in
mariopol has appealed for international
help to get his forces out of the
besieged city in a video message a major
asahi voliner said his forces could be
facing their last days if not hours
we appeal to the world it could be the
last appeal of our lives these could be
our last days if not ours
we appeal and plead to all world leaders
to help us
we ask them to extract us from here and
to take us to the territory of a
third-party state
well with access to mario paul all but
cut off our correspondent rebecca
ritters is following the latest
developments from kiev i asked her what
she's hearing about the devastated port
it's really coming down to the wire for
that besieged city as you just heard
phil that commander there pleading for
their lives saying that they really only
have days if not hours left we know that
the ukrainian soldiers are outnumbered
at least one to ten and the russians
have been
bombarding excuse me that city for weeks
they are of course holed up in that as
of steel plants with a vast network of
warehouses and underground tunnels
there's believed to be around about a
thousand civilians also taking shelter
down there but as you heard in that
report russians now trying to use bunker
busting bombs to try and get underground
to really be able to reach those
soldiers remaining there underground
we do think that mariupol will fall to
the russians in the coming hours and
days but really
the ukrainians will be hailed heroes
regardless they've done what they set
out to do and that's really hold up the
russian resources and soldiers from
going elsewhere in this war so
definitely those soldiers looking to
lose that city
shortly
but will be hailed heroes nonetheless
right and now the russian offensive in
don bass seems to be well underway
yes that picked up really uh that
expected bombardment of the don bass and
of the eastern region really picked up
yesterday more than 1200 targets hit by
artillery and missile fire by the
russians
the russians managed to take their first
town cremina
they they were able to take that from
the ukrainians their first win in the
eastern assault but the ukrainians also
managed to retake a town that's very
close to the city of donetsk
so wins on both sides there
the ukrainians
say that this is a very decisive
phase this second phase of the war uh
so definitely uh picking up pace there
phil
and so how are people there in the
capital reacting to these developments
there's some frustration uh you could
say from the capital about just how much
support they're getting from the west
again president zielinski in his nightly
message calling
for more weapons he said if they had the
weapons they needed they could have
already won this war
so you know some frustration there that
not more is being done to support them
some planes uh u.s planes and parts have
started arriving from that 800 million
uh dollar aid package that was agreed
last week and more is on the way
it is believed that another aid package
will be
agreed to by the u.s but frustration
that other european countries for
example haven't done more that they're
only starting to discuss still knowing
having known for at least two weeks that
this offensive was starting to going to
take place but they're only discussing
still maybe what they will send so
really some frustration there was
zelinski saying that they could have
already won this and that it's a very
decisive phase not just for ukraine but
for the rest of europe as well so
feeling slightly alone in this battle
phil okay thank you for that rebecca
ritters in kiev
well let's get more on russia's
offensive in ukraine's east from frank
ledwich he's a former military
intelligence officer you know lectures
in military capabilities and strategy at
the university of portsmouth welcome to
dw what's your understanding of the
progress russia is making in this
eastern assault
well they've started what's called the
artillery preparation and some initial
probing attacks such as kremnina which
your correspondent mentioned it's quite
a small town actually which has been
fought over for a number of years or at
least contested
they are not really set or ready for
this operation something of this size
would really take several months to set
up they've had a few weeks
there needs to be logistics networks
fully and fully protected and secure and
so forth all kinds of things they should
have done haven't because it speaks
actually of a lot of pressure on the
russians to get things done and i think
that's going to back fire on them so to
answer your question directly it's
raining now it's it's warm it's going to
be a terrible day for the defenders lots
of people are going to get killed but
the russians are uh are are in some
trouble i think from uh from the
perspective preparation
all right so when we look at these two
sides they do appear mismatched um
is there any doubt that russia would
will ultimately take donbass
yes i think there's plenty of doubt this
is going to be like any battle of this
kind of this nature artillery and armor
ground war it's a war or a battle of
attrition and the side which can sustain
its logistics and supply will prevail in
that battle which is why president
zielenski quite rightly is so concerned
about maintaining or increasing and then
maintaining that stream of weaponry
particularly as you said heavy weaponry
which needs to get there to be able to
essentially slug it out with the
russians they were talking artillery
armor armor personnel cars things like
that as well as maintaining their
defenses
all right um going back to what your
your first answer there you you said
that this this
if russia has not prepared this uh
assault properly and you said that this
speaks to uh pressure on russian forces
and it certainly sounds like russian
military commanders being taken by
surprise by their political leaders
yes i think i think well strategically
speaking that's certainly the case
that's perhaps taken more by surprise by
their appalling route in the north
and being forced to to reallocate the
axis of the main attack to the south
and you would expect really this
preparation phase to have taken a couple
of months and we've had it in a couple
of couple of weeks
so the russians are going to run into
run into difficulties
they
are going to face an enemy however which
is very well prepared
and has been preparing for a number of
years for an attack like this
and of course an enemy that's
demonstrated itself to be operationally
and tactically
far more efficient if they're given the
weapons to complete their task which at
the moment
is in the balance that this issue of
question of um
of supply of weaponry
and if russia actually takes uh donbass
a part of the the russian justification
for this is denatification and to to
liberate uh people uh in the russian
native speakers um uh from
the so-called nazis what sort of welcome
will they get once they're there given
that that uh ukrainian forces have been
fighting russian proxies to a standstill
for years
yes very interesting question phil it's
worth worth
mentioning i think that mariopol which
is now
in flames and
in much of it in rubble with many
thousands of its citizens dead was
traditionally considered a very
pro-russian city
and many people i would suspect i don't
know but in donbass maybe looking at
that and thinking well have we been have
we've been um backing the wrong the
wrong side but who knows
the the issue is now in the hands of
artillery crews and tank crews and of
course the excellent ukrainian light
infantry with their western supplied
missiles
good perhaps though
we need yeah thanks so much all right
thank you so much for that uh former
military officer frank ledwich
you